The landscape gizmo brush is one of the other tools that we can use to modify or affect our landscapes look and feel.
Unlike the brush tools, this one allows us to do the following.
We can either copy existing parts of our landscape and then paste them to other locations in our landscape.
Or for our example what we're going to do is we're actually going to use this tool to import a height map
and then use the gizmo to place where inside of our landscape that height map should affect.
Now one of the advantages of doing it this way is that the gizmo import export supports the R16 height map option.
The reason this is so beneficial is that when you're using the R16 height map format,
you're going to greatly reduce the amount of artifacts or stair stepping patterns that you see inside of the landscape.
Now these stair stepping artifacts are easy to fix, but they can be a little annoying, especially as you're crafting your landscape.
So for us, what we're going to do as soon as we select our height map, we then need to change our height map size.
And this is going to be based off of the size of the texture.
So for our example, our texture is going to be 2048 by 2048.
So we're going to put that number in. And then once we hit import, we're going to get something that looks like this.
The gizmo brush will reflect the look of the texture that we've used to import as our height map.
And then we can go through our level and add this content to our landscape wherever we want,
by either utilizing the brush to paint it in or by pressing control V on the keyboard to paste things into our landscape.
So let's go ahead and look at that now.
So we're going to come over here, make sure we have our landscape and our sculpt, and I'm going to come to our copy.
And generally it looks like this.
So we're going to come down here to our advanced.
We're going to make sure gizmo import export.
We're going to select our height map, which is in this case going to be our impact crater.
So I'm going to hit open.
We know our size here is going to be 2048 by 2048.
So that's good.
And there's our gizmo right there.
So let's go ahead and hit import and give this just a moment to update.
And that is what it looks like. There we go.
So let's go ahead and hit control V right now.
And let's just look at G to see what this does.
So there it is.
It is doing it kind of in a circle here.
So there's a couple of ways that we could get rid of that.
We could turn off this use smooth gizmo brush to kind of get all the way into the edges there.
The other thing that we can do, too, is this is going to be directly related to the height.
So as I kind of sink this down into our landscape, you can see here it has made some really great little craters in this area.
And then if I was to kind of bring this up, maybe move it over here.
Let me just get out of the way and kind of bring this all the way up.
You're going to see I'll hit control V and it's going to actually raise kind of everything up to meet that area right there.
So just keep that in mind that when you're using this tool, the location of this matters the most.
And we can also affect things in both the positive and the negative.
One of the other things is if we change this pace mode, for example, if I hit this just to like lower and hit control V,
it's going to push everything down for me. But I do need to make sure that I am relatively close
or protruding inside of the height map here to get that to work very well.
So if I was to do the raise something similar, it's going to raise this stuff up.
So there we go. Just raised everything.
Probably going to bring this up just a little bit more to get some more stuff raised up.
So there we go. So that looks actually looks kind of cool there on the side of the mountain.
So what I want everybody to do now is just spend the next few minutes taking this landscape gizmo and adjusting it.
We can move it around. We can also rotate it and we can also scale it.
So spend some time just adjusting this and scaling it and playing with the values.
And we'll see you in just a little bit with the next part in our tutorial.